najat vallaud belkacem bonjour et merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
cette décision des pays du g20 va dans
le bon sens mais donc pas assez selon
vous on l'a vu vous déplorez que la
l'arrêt du service de la dette n'est pas
été prolongé jusqu'à la fin 2021 mais
uniquement donc jusqu'au 30 juin
prochain c'est donc une demi mesure
selon vous oui c'est une demi mesure que
les choses soient claires si rien n'est
fait or aujourd'hui à part de repousser
de quelques mois pas grand chose n'a été
décidé eh bien ce sont plus de 50
milliards de dollars que les pays les
plus pauvres du monde vont devoir dans
les quinze mois qui viennent on
remboursé au titre de leur dette
50 milliards de dollars vous imaginez
comment est-ce que cette somme serait
mieux utilisé pour eux à renforcer leurs
systèmes de santé à venir en aide à
leurs populations qui souffrent des
mêmes difficultés économiques que celle
que nous connaissons et bien sûr bien
plus grave pour ce qui les concerne
puisque ces deux familles que l'on parle
dans un certain nombre de ces pays ils
sont quand même bien me voir à l'esprit
que dans tous les pays riches on a
compris que le coït 19 nous avait mis
dans une situation tellement
exceptionnel qu'il fallait qu'on dépense
de l'argent et pays du g20 par exemple
en moyenne ils ont dépensé 20 % de leur
pib en plan de relance pour soutenir
l'économie pour fournir des traitements
etc
et bien c'est 20 % de leur pib qu'ils
ont pu dépenser les pays les plus
pauvres ne les ont pas car ils sont trop
occupés à devoir rembourser des dettes
donc voilà pourquoi est ce qu'on
attendait du g20 comme on attend
d'ailleurs de la banque mondiale qui est
aussi un créancier et créanciers s'est
pas seulement les états quand on parle
de la dette des pays les plus pauvres du
monde on parle pas seulement des
créanciers est un riche qui eux ont déjà
fait quelques efforts on parle aussi des
banques multilatérales comme la banque
mondiale
on parle aussi des créanciers privés
comme les fonds de pension les grandes
banques et tous ses acteurs doivent
aujourd'hui comprendre que la situation
est si exceptionnelle que il faut
suspendre cette tête voire pour un
certain nombre de pays l'annuler
pourquoi le g20 n'est donc pas aller
plus loin selon vous je pense que c'est
un manque d'ambition c'est bien ce que
nous reprochons en l'occurrence parce
que on peut pas non plus dire que le g20
n'est passé mais rien c'est la vérité
c'est que depuis le printemps dernier il
avait réagit finalement assez rapidement
avec son initiative de suspension du
service de la dette et que cette
initiative a eu des effets positifs
puisque à ce jour comme vous l'avez
rappelé c'est quand même 43 pays parmi
les pays les plus pauvres du monde qui
bénéficie d'une suspension
c'est environ 5 milliards de dollars
cette suspension pour les pays concernés
ça veut dire que grosso modo c'est des
dépenses de santé qui peuvent faire en
plus sur leur propre territoire
pourquoi est ce que le g20 ne va pas
plus loin
je pense parce qu'on navigue un peu à
vue pour le moment et c'est toute la
problématique de ce sujet nous nous
estimons holloway jawad que la question
de la restructuration des pets devrait
être posée dans un cercle international
qui est souffre aucune contestation qui
pourrait être l'onu par exemple qui
mettent autour de la table
aussi bien les créanciers publics que
les créanciers privés que les banques
multilatérales et ça ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui c'est un défaut de
gouvernance
ce qui fait que en réalité bas on passe
d'une réunion avec d'autres ministres
des g20
bah vous en avez des volontariste parmi
eux puis des moins bons tarifs tous les
pays ne sont pas sur la même longueur
d'ondés et c'est comme ça qu'on se
retrouve avec des mesures qui ne sont
malheureusement pas parfaite
le g20 a toutefois même évoqué l'idée
donc d'une restructuration de la dette
ce serait une sorte de cas par cas ce
que vous pensez que ça pourrait être une
solution à court terme le lit des dalles
est de faire du cas par cas s'agissant
de ce qu'on appelle à la restructuration
c'est à dire la potentielle annulation
entraîne
oui c'est une idée qui se tient c'est à
dire que plutôt que de décider d'une
adulation général
voilà dès aujourd'hui pour tous les pays
les plus pauvres du monde où vous dites
donc on suspend et ensuite on fait une
clause de revoyure ou au bout d'un an
par exemple on regarde quels sont les
pays qui ont vraiment pas réussi à
redresser la situation pour lesquelles
ça va vraiment très mal qui marie ont de
toute façon pas remboursés et là on
adule donc l'idée de procéder au cas par
cas s'agissant de la décision lourde
d'annuler complètement une bête elle me
paraît logique mais pour qu'elles aient
du sens il faut que le temps de
suspension qu'il est précédée soit
suffisamment important s'il n'est que de
quelques mois ce temps de suspension
honnêtement en quoi est-ce que la
situation épidémique ou économique aura
changé d'ici le mois de décembre parce
que c'est ça le sujet c'est que il faut
que le temps de suspension soit
suffisamment bon pour que un déclic et
pu avoir lieu ou pas d'avoir lieu et
ensuite décider ou pas d'annuler les
dettes donc là nous demandons vraiment
aux gens de reprendre à nouveau ces
discussions pour prolonger encore son
initiative de suspension jusqu'à la fin
c'était ça notre demande et nous
demandons surtout aux institutions
multilatérales et aux créanciers privés
de faire partie de cet effort également
dernière question najat vallaud belkacem
finalement ce que vous expliquez aussi
c'est que de nombreux pays du monde sont
sont face à un fois c'est sauver des
vies ou rembourser leurs dettes donc
dans ce contexte de pandémie
oui on peut déjà il faut quand même
qu'on ait conscience peut être dû du
nombre de gens dont on parle aujourd'hui
c'est au bas mot 425 millions de
personnes qui vivent dans des pays en
situation de surendettement ou à haut
risque de surendettement 425 millions de
personnes si vous voulez si il
s'agissait d'un de la population d'un
pays ce serait le troisième plus grand
pays du monde après la chine et l'inde
donc c'est énormément de gens que l'on
parle c'est population ces pays pauvres
ils sont en train de traverser une crise
mais inouïe inouï
on vous l'avait dit ces 150 millions de
pauvres
clément terre extrême pauvreté
supplémentaires qui sont attendus ces
pays des plus pauvres ils ont des pertes
en termes de production économique
considérable estimée par exemple juste
pour l'année 2020 à 120 milliards de
dollars voilà donc c'est vraiment une
situation particulière dans laquelle est
bien trop occupé à essayer de finalement
découpé de deux plans dire de parer au
plus urgent en matière économique
on n'a pas les moyens de financer des
millions de tests covit 19 qu'il
faudrait les millions de masques il
faudrait pour les citoyens parce que des
citoyens c'est les mêmes là bas est chez
nous ils ont besoin de masques et de
tests aussi donc on est dans une
pandémie extrêmement grave et des pays
les plus pauvres ne doivent pas se
retrouver à avoir le choix entre
rembourser leurs dettes ou maintenir
leurs populations et leur économie à
flot
il faut qu'on leur laisse de la
possibilité vraiment vraiment de
s'occuper de la priorité des priorités
c'est à dire l'humain et l'économique
chez eux d'abord avant que ce soit
tellement grave que rien ne soit
rattrapable merci beaucoup najat vallaud
belkacem
pour toutes ces raisons je rappelle que
vous êtes directrice france de l' ong
one